Hannity we are in beautiful Cedar Rapids
Iowa what a great fun crowd we have
with GOP front runner Donald J Trump and
we continue so we just got done talking
about China Russia Iran North Korea and
we have a little problem here and that
is the Biden family Joe Biden said to
this country repeatedly during your 2020
election that he never once spoke with
his son Hunter about his foreign
business dealings now
[Applause]
that he leveraged one billion taxpayer
dollars to get a prosecutor fired in
Ukraine right okay and as a result son
of a b they fired him and then Hunter
continued to get paid Hunter goes on
Good Morning America I have no
experience in oil gas energy or Ukraine
why are they paying you all that money
he actually said I don't know I mean a
50 year old man okay here's my bigger
question though now we know about the
WhatsApp message which said I am sitting
here with my father
and we now have photographic evidence we
have times and places of meetings of Joe
and Hunter and farm business partners
all meeting and they have found all of
these bank accounts James Comer is now
saying it's up to 30 maybe 40 million
dollars uh in business the Biden family
I want an answer to this question do you
believe with all the millions that they
did in business with China and Russia
and Ukraine and Kazakhstan and Romania
and and and Mexico and all these
countries
is that why Russia got the Nordstrom 2
pipeline is that why there were no
consequences for the spy drone uh fly
that China sent and or their hostility
towards our Navy and Air Force so are
they are they compromised I think no
question about it look you have China
paying millions of dollars just just
that one conversation which sounded like
a mobster conversation
they got five million dollars then they
got another 5.2 million I guess from the
same group so they got 10.2 million that
comes from China and that's only one
that they've covered so far I understand
they have much more than that's the
energy giant what about Ukraine so we've
given and we want to help people we want
we have a heart we got to help people
too but we're in for almost 200 billion
dollars in Ukraine and Europe is in for
20 billion dollars why are we and you
know Europe is essentially the same size
as us or the economy if you add it all
up Europe and the US are about the same
size why isn't Europe in for 200 or more
than us why aren't thing and they're
affected much more than us because
nobody asked them you know I asked them
for the money for NATO because the U.S
is paying for NATO and Europe by the way
treats us very badly on trade not so
much anymore but that's going to change
because they're back to their old ways
but why aren't they I got hundreds of
billions of dollars for these countries
by asking all they had to do is ask I
asked they said are you going to protect
us from Russia I said are you delinquent
they said let's assume we were I said I
will not protect you from Russia and
then the money started pouring we got
hundreds of billions of dollars coming
in and they were very happy but but look
at Ukraine where Hunter's getting
hundreds of thousands a month and like I
guess from what they say a 3 million
upfront payment to sit in an energy
company and he knows nothing about
energy uh the debate so I had a debate
and Chris Wallace who was terrible he
sure is not his father he's not the
great Mike Wallace he wants to be but he
doesn't have the talent but Chris
Wallace is terrible and I mentioned to
him that why is the mayor of moscow's
wife paying the Biden family three and a
half million dollars and he said you
shouldn't ask that question I said why
not and Joe was trying to answer it but
he couldn't answer it it wasn't going
well and Chris Wallace cut me off he
said you shouldn't I said I have two
people I'm debating not one the one I
definitely don't mind but Chris Walsh
how's he doing lately Chris Wells not
too good not too good like two people
are watching this show but here's the
story
so Russia is giving them massive amounts
of money Ukraine's giving a massive
amounts of money and China's giving a
massive amounts of money and then there
are many other countries also
it's horrible it's horrible they
compromise Joe Biden is a compromised
president and you know what until I got
indicted
until I got indicted I had such respect
for the Office of the President I didn't
want to say things I would do numbers in
him and you know but you actually yelled
at me once for being too tough out no I
thought you were joking too much I
thought you should take it seriously
because I think it's I talked about Joe
and his cognitive he's a cognitive mess
everyone agree yeah you know so but John
was making sort of Comedy out of it and
I said honestly Sean it's a serious
problem because we have we're in the
nuclear age and we have a man in charge
of our country you were right who
doesn't have a clue and I said there's
nothing funny about it and I did tell
her that there is nothing funny and he
sort of changed a lot and by the way
this man is doing very well on
television I don't know if you watch
ratings but his ratings are very good oh
thank you because he never says I always
say why didn't you take the commercial
saying how successful your show is how
good your ratings are nah it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter but uh he's a
good man and he loves this country I can
tell you but they are compromised show
on we have a compromised president China
gives him millions of dollars if he's
given Biden millions of dollars he's
compromised now that's only the stuff
they found there's a lot of other things
and there'll be some things that you
never find but there's a lot of other
things so he's getting millions of
dollars illegally from China and then
you say hey they impeached me over a
phone call that was perfect why aren't
they impeaching Biden for receiving tens
of millions of dollars why isn't he
under impeachment
I know we're at a point where 60 some
odd percent of Americans live in
paycheck to paycheck yeah in my early
adult life I live paycheck to paycheck I
could barely pay my rent that was for a
number of years I know what it's like
it's not fun
um we have the average American now has
54 000 in debt Biden inflation has cost
the average American household over ten
thousand dollars a year we can't afford
this on top of 37 trillion in debt
how quickly and what would you do to get
this economy turned around it'll go so
quickly number one I'm closing that
border like I had it we had the best
and by the way I think you all agree
I think you all of this
we want people to come into our country
but we want them to come in Legally we
had a good system they were taking tests
we want people that love our our country
not people that want to blow up our
shopping centers and our Farms so we I
want people but I would make our border
so strong and get off the criminals we
have many criminals in our country now
that weren't here three years ago I will
get them out ice
I will drill baby drill you know the
expression
you'll get energy way down when energy
comes down inflation's going to come
down all right more with our town hall
we're in Cedar Rapids Iowa with Donald
Trump Straight Ahead hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else